[Musique]
il est au centre de l'hémicycle et au
cœur du système parlementaire le
président de l'Assemblée nationale et le
quatrième personnage de l'État il est
élu pour 5 ans par ses collègues députés
et sa mission principale garantir avant
tout le bon déroulé des débats dans
l'hémicycle je vous explique c'est lui
qui fixe l'ordre du jour avant chaque
séance pendant les discussions il décide
de l'ordre des interventions et donne la
parole aux députés il s'assure qu'il
respecte le temps qui leur est un parti
pour s'exprimer
il a aussi un rôle d'arbitre pour que
les débats se fassent dans de bonnes
conditions et dans le respect du
règlement de l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
mais le rôle du président ne se limite
pas à l'hémicycle il a aussi un pouvoir
de saisine d'autres institutions voire
de nominations de certains de leurs
membres
ce pouvoir de saisine signifie que avant
qu'une loi ne soit promulguée il peut
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel pour
savoir si elle est conforme à la
Constitution
avant qu'une proposition de loi ne soit
examinée en commission il peut aussi
demander l'avis du Conseil d'État du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental ou de l'art comme
tout comme le président du Sénat le
président de l'Assemblée nomme les
membres d'autres institutions trois
membres du Conseil constitutionnel 2 du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature ou
encore deux de l'arcom
autre mission la diplomatie
parlementaire le président représente
l'Assemblée nationale lorsqu’il se
rendent à l'étranger ou qui leur reçoit
des chefs d'État en France les chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement étrangers en
visite diplomatiques à Paris font
souvent une halte à l’assemblée
nationale le président les reçoit dans
sa résidence à l'hôtel de lacet accolée
au Palais Bourbon
conférence des présidents des assemblées
parlementaires européennes sommet des
présidents des Parlement du G7 le
président représente aussi la France en
ces gens dans des instances
internationales
[Musique]